This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. A home world cup only happens once in a lifetime, and we are not missing a second. I'm Castle 1021. On the 1021 podcast, me and the crew, break down every match like it's personal, the drama, the upsets, the debates you'll be having all day,
soccer, culture, and chaos in one place. Pick aside, we already did. Listen to the 1021 podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of
Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song.
I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.A.O. Rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? It's sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the hosts of everyone watches women's sports. A new podcast from Together. We're breaking down the biggest headlines, the viral moments, and the story
everyone's talking about across women's sports. From game-changing performances to culture-shifting conversations, we'll give you our takes, our debates, and a few laughs along the way. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the I-Heart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea.
Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier, and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
My first guest is Territ Hilton, Shakira, Luke, and Yerrin. Have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast where the group check comes to life. What on? You're the only person I know that loves. a yellow starburst. It's lemonade.
This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast and welcome to another bonus episode of the psychology of your 20s. This is a special mini-series. We're running within the podcast where we break down psychology concepts, theories and figures which have become vastly popular beyond the psychology space, especially online. And we essentially, give you the real facts and we myth bust some of the bogus information and ideas we have about these things or which are kind of promoted in online spaces. We've done dopamine. We've done
Maslow's hierarchy of needs. We have myth busted the legend that our frontal lobe develops at 25. We've done personality tests. But today we have the big cahuna of all episodes when it comes to psychology law. We are going to talk about none other than the infamous, the notorious, the famous, the well-known Sigmund Freud, the figure that I think has come to define modern psychology more than any other figure, maybe more than any other concept, and has also prompted a lot of misconceptions about psychology and the field of therapy in general. I'm not going to waste any time because we have a lot to talk about. This man, the man, the myth, the legend, got up to so many things during his life and his legacy is almost as big as what he actually
did. And I'm just going to tell you, this episode takes turns that you will never believe. Cocaine is mentioned. Feminism. Weird sexual beliefs he had. There is a lot to discuss. So let's get into it. So let's start. with the basics, who was Sigmund Freud. If you had never heard of him before, what would you need to know? So Sigmund Freud is, as I alluded to, just like the grandfather of modern psychology. He created an entire new perspective on the human mind, human emotions, human souls, and it's called psychoanalysis. More on that later, before he became the creator of psychoanalysis and
the famous name and figure of today. He was born in 1856 in what was then the Austrian Empire. At the time, Austria was very much the center of psychological thought and research. It was where so many major figures were teaching, learning, being born. His family later moved to Vienna. That's where he spent most of his life and his career. I was literally in Vienna last week. and I was, I didn't go to the Freud Museum and I knew it was there and I was just kicking myself. I just didn't have time. I went cycling and I went on a wine tour instead. So definitely a lot of fun but yeah, I didn't go and apparently it's amazing and apparently
it's literally his offices with his original couch, with his original carpeting, furnishing. If you look up a photo of Freud's office, it's very distinct. But just a reason to go back to Vienna, I guess. But he lived there. He lived in Austria. He lived in Vienna. with his family, with his daughter, up until his death, more on her later. But he, he didn't start out doing psychology as we know it today. He didn't start out thinking the things that he went on
to think, obviously. He actually trained as a medical doctor. And he began his professional life in neurology. He was medically trained. He was very interested in the nervous system, in the brain. He wanted to help people with things like epilepsy, with forgetfulness, coordination issues. But he became very interested in patients who's, they had physical symptoms, but they didn't have a physical explanation. So they had things like paralysis, like pain, fainting, distress, compulsion, speech difficulties, all these other things. And physicians of the time couldn't account for them medically.
they couldn't account for them really, they didn't think about them as emotional either. And so at the time he was working in specifically in neurology, but back then, psychiatry, neurology, psychology, they weren't really divided up in the way they are today. It was just kind of one big pot of things to do with the body and the brain and the mind. And many of the symptoms that they were observing, which were physical but also emotional in nature, they just got grouped together and they were given a specific diagnosis of hysteria or hysteria, depending on how you pronounce it. This is a term that we would not use today, right?
We wouldn't say that somebody has hysteria. It's very loaded with gendered assumptions about women's bodies, women's emotions, credibility. In fact, about 80% of the people who were diagnosed with hysteria were women. And even the symptoms, the way that it was described, was agended. So it included things like wanting to have too much sex as a woman, but equally not wanting to have any sex at all, relationship dissatisfaction, sadness in the home, but then also enthusiasm, being too passionate. That was another criteria. So not the nicest or the most accurate
or the most helpful of diagnosis that you could get at the time, but Freud saw this and he wanted to understand this label and the suffering beneath it in a way that was just a bit more articulate and structured and organized and went deeper than that current level. For his time, the way he went about this was really scientific. I think that's a very crucial part. You know, when we look at his work and some of the things that he does, which we'll talk about in a second, we often look at it through the lens of the time period that we are in now, where we're kind of like, that's probably not okay. That's probably not scientific. But we need to. We need. to understand where he was at. You know, he was operating before there was any kind of brain
imagery, before there was any kind of, you know, modern trauma science. It was pre-randomized control groups, pre-developmental psychology, pre-ethics bodies. And it was born out of the context of Victorian era assumptions about sex, gender, class, family, respect, rules. We're talking here about somebody who was very rapid. for his period of time, he was also deeply limited by it. But the thing is, is that we couldn't have gotten to where we were without him. Like, he really pushed the needle. He really tried things. He really attempted to construct what we now call a method or a hypothesis or a sample size or an intervention. So what was he actually doing? What was he actually trying out that was so
quote unquote radical? So early on, he was influenced by this one case. And this was really really what kind of pushed him into doing more scientific things. It was the case of Bertha Pappenheim. She's also known as Anna O. So that was her pseudonym that he wrote about her as Anna O. And she was experiencing like really distressing symptoms. She was experiencing paralysis, hallucinations, visual disturbances, confusion. And at the time, she was also looking after her dying father. Freud was very close to this case. He was a medical student at the time. He was a medical student at the time, he was watching it. He wrote so much about it because it suggested that physical seeing symptoms might be connected to emotional experiences. And he kind of put that forward.
He goes, you know, we're trying to find a parasite. We're trying to find something that's wrong with her brain. We're trying to explain this through all these different avenues. Did anybody just think to ask her about how she's coping with her dad? Did anybody just think to go into her childhood and her early memories with her father and how they might be making this particularly distressing. And this really shaped what became psychoanalysis, the talking cure. Essentially what Freud said was that human pain is like, kind of like a parasite in the body that needs to be extracted. Talking through emotionally charged memories, revealing emotionally charged moments, being honest about your feelings and about your past,
you know, digging below the surface of human desire and human thought, that is what allows that extraction. That is what helps ease physical symptoms. I also want to say side note, Anna O, back to her. She, yes, in Freud's work was written under a pseudonym, but Bertha, the woman who was Anna O, she actually went on to become a very famous writer. She was a very, very well-known social worker. She was a very well-known feminist. She was a major figure in German-Jewish women's welfare and did a lot of activism. So a little bit of a side note for the history of this. She was also pretty incredible. So then Freud moved on. He went to Paris and he studied under a very famous neurologist called Jean-Martin-Sharkot. I always butcher the French. I'm sorry. If you're French,
oh, you speak French. I know what that sounds. That's probably know how it said. But look, up John Martin Jockot in Paris and this is when he started learning about things like hypnosis and interrogation and suggestion to help patients access memories or feelings that were buried very deep in the unconscious mind. Over time though, he kind of moved away from that. He, this was his first kind of step towards modern practices. He moved away from hypnosis in particular because he realized you know, it just didn't work for everybody. It also wasn't entirely accurate and he wanted something that felt a little bit less stressful. And so he developed a now very famous method called free association. This is a very important term. One of the terms most associated with Freud, free association. It was a method where he essentially found ways to get patients to say whatever came to mind, whatever memories they were thinking, even if it was embarrassing, irrelevant, repetitive, strange. He wasn't. He wasn't. He was, he was wanted it to just come out. He just wanted them to just spill their guts, basically. He also did dream analysis. So he really felt that our memories and our pain and our trauma and what was
bothering us was revealed through dreams, because that was when the subconscious mind is most relaxed. But at its simplest form, all of these are methods of psychoanalysis. And psychoanalysis was this theory that underneath our conscious thoughts, our conscious patterns, our conscious behaviors are these wishes and these fears and these conflicts and these memories and defenses that we don't fully recognize that are seeping through. And once you discover those influences, once you tear apart those conditions, I guess, that is when you can help somebody with their conscious problems, with their everyday issues. Today, like the idea that talking about your feelings might help you or thinking about your past might help you or thinking about your
unconscious motivations might help you is pretty obvious. But back then it wasn't. And Freud helped move Western mental health care towards this idea that, again, physical or behavioral symptoms have a psychological emotional meaning. And if you were to listen carefully to somebody's inner world, you could help them. And that's where, like, that's where what he did was very, very powerful. Should also be said, he did some other things. He tried in order to access the unconscious mind, or the pre-conscious mind, he experimented with a lot of ways of doing this. Cocaine was the other one. He, Freud, in the early days of his career, loved cocaine.
He loved using it. He loved prescribing it. He loved giving it away. He thought it not only lowered inhibitions, so allowing for greater free association, but he also called it the miracle drug for depression and other mood disorders. And he wrote this massive, massive, massive. paper called Uber drug, because of course he spoke German, about it. And it was like it like went the equivalent of like viral like back in the day. A lot of people were reading this. And then he went
back on that. Later in his life, he was like, I think cocaine is awful. I would not prescribe it. I do not use it. The reason why he accidentally, well accidentally, I don't think he intended this to happen, which is why it was an accident. But he did, he got one of the. of his best friends addicted to cocaine. Like seriously dependent and he saw this man suffering with addiction and he saw him like his life just like be derailed and he was like, okay, so maybe that's not the solution. Let's talk about some of his other famous ideas and other famous things associated with Freud, one of them being him and his couch. I think it is the typical image of Freud to have him in a chair, his patient laying on their back on a couch, reciting their dreams, being asked about their
mother and their father whilst he takes notes, being shown inklots and asking them, you know, what do you see here? Is that accurate? Yeah, there is actually a big grain of truth to this idea. Freud did use a couch, as was apparently in the museum that I didn't see, but apparently the couch is there. He did ask patients to speak freely. He did interpret. dreams, slips of the tongue, known as Freudian slips, childhood memories. But it wasn't as freestyles as we think. So he wasn't just like, come in and just chat about it. He had a very strict set of questions. He had certain criteria. He had theories. He had structures. He also had this method of sitting out, like directly out of the line of sight of the patient because he
believed it helped them speak more freely. He believed it was important. He believed it was important. to not feel like there was somebody analyzing you, even if that is what was happening. He kept very diligent case notes. And the other part about Freud's method was that he was really aware of the role of something called transference. This is the idea that feelings from early relationships, parents, siblings, even early romantic relationships can be replayed in the therapy relationship. So for example, a patient might experience a therapist as rejecting or critical or comforting or
maybe authoritative, not because of what the therapist is doing in the room, not because they are rejecting them or judging them, not because they are critical, but because of old relational patterns that are being activated or reactivated through the interaction. A therapist can feel like a parent or a teacher at times, which is not what we're what we want them to feel like. And Freud was very aware of that. This was one of his biggest contributions that I don't think many people talk about in which he doesn't get much credit for.
He recognized that therapy is not just confined to a discussion about the patient's life outside of the therapy room. What is happening in the therapy room, how they see the therapist, the relationship between the person trying to help and the person needing help, and all the baggage that they come in with as individuals becomes a huge part of that work and and becomes a huge part of whether somebody's therapy or treatment is successful. So that's how he went about treatment. Beyond that, what were his actual core theories? Something interesting that is still very common for psychologists these days to do. Less so then it was very common was that they would practice and they would help people
and then they would also research and they would contribute ideas. So they'd spend kind of 50-50 of the time, seeing clients, seeing patients, having that exposure to real people, and then the other amount of the time hypothesizing, writing articles. They weren't doing experiments on the grand scale that we would now expect in psychology. They were just kind of theorizing based on what they saw. This is what Freud's core theories are. Firstly, we have briefly mentioned the idea of conscious, pre-conscious, and the unconscious mind and how psychoanalysis is really concerned with the unconscious mind and what's going on in that
kind of labyrinth. This is often explained and you would have seen it using the iceberg metaphor. So if you've ever seen when you were in high school or in uni or just literally your workplace or like in a therapist office, an iceberg that says, you know, the conscious mind is the top and then all that's below is the pre-conscious unconscious. That was Freud's idea. And he again believed that there was this large amount of what influenced our behavior and our attitudes and our personality and who we were that we could not touch or even feel or kind of see. Now there are certain aspects of this that aren't accepted in modern psychology, but the broader idea that mental processes happen outside of our conscious awareness is pretty widely accepted.
Cognitive psychology, social psychology, neuroscience, trauma therapy, like all those things. They all recognize this as an important thing and something that does occur. Tickster Freud, he was the one who kind of started that. Another major contribution is Freud's structural model of the mind. He believed that the mind wasn't just made up of conscious, pre-conscious, unconscious, or subconscious. It was made up of the id, the ego, and the super ego. We have spoken about this at length on the podcast before. But essentially, the term ego, the way that we use the word ego is not as Freud initially
thought of it as. You know, it has been misunderstood. For him, well, we'll start with the id first. So the id, the ego, the super ego, the id is the instinctual, impulsive part of your mind. It is the part of you that wants immediate satisfaction. It's associated with pleasure, aggression, hunger, sexuality, desire, doesn't care about consequences. It doesn't care about what is socially acceptable. It just wants, it craves. The super ego is the opposite. It represents internalized rules, morality, guilt, ideals, expectations.
It's the part of you that is critical, that is overly cautious. And the ego sits between them. Ego doesn't mean arrogance. For him, ego meant self-awareness, balancing. It meant the brain's in the part of our brain that negotiates between desire and morality, reality and consequences. So if the id wants something immediately and this super ego shames you for wanting that, the ego is the part that's trying to manage the conflict in a way that allows us, the person, to function. And I think that captures something very recognizable in us as humans. We often experience a conflict between what we want, what we think we should want, and what reality allows for or what is deemed acceptable.
Another key contribution beyond the id, the super ego, the ego and the unconscious, oh my God, so many unconscious, preconduous, subconscious, he had a lot of terms, is his idea of psychosexual development. Now, this is one of Freud's most famous and most controversial ideas, and you have definitely heard of it before. Definitely. There are too many pop culture references to count at this stage. Freud proposed that, this is the part you may not have heard of, I will say.
Freud proposed that children move through different stages of development. There is the oral, the anal, the phallic, latency, and genital stages graphic. But he believed that unresolved conflicts at each of these stages shapes our personalities as adults. For example, he argued that if a child experienced frustration or, overindulgence during the oral stage, which centers on feeding and sucking, they might become overly dependent on habits like smoking or overeating or nail biting later in life, because that is how they learned to suit themselves. During the anal stage, which focuses on toilet training, so it's not all sexual, it's just intimate.
Overly strict parenting in the anal stage might produce somebody who is very orderly, who is a perfectionist, very controlling. And lacks parenting during the stage means that somebody becomes messy or impulsive. And he believed that these kind of unresolved tensions, which he called fixations, would leave a lasting imprint on how people think, how people behave, how they relate to others as adults.
This is also where the famous Oedipus complex comes in. In Freud's theory, during the phallic stage, A young child, it gets a bit weird from here, just a heads up, a young child he believed develops unconscious feelings of desire for the opposite sex parent and therefore a sense of rivalry with the same sex parent to win the opposite sex parents' attention. Now, he focused specifically on boys. He argued that boys unconsciously desire their mother and see their fathers as rivals and fear punishment from him. He also believed that this process was important for the development of the
super ego. Then that essentially resolving this is what allows us to understand what is right. And that incest is not okay. There's also the female version of this, which is the Electra complex. I think it goes without saying it's not entirely accurate, if not accurate at all. It's very heteronormative. Freud was known to make a lot of things unnecessarily about sex, including child development, which is obviously a little bit odd. Not a little bit, it's quite odd that he was very fixated on this. But yeah, he made a lot of things about sex that didn't need to be about sex, like parental conflict or, you know, growing up or being a teenager or being a messy person, you know, has nothing to do with sex and all these things, but he really made it so. And this is an example of that. The last
famous theory of his we're going to talk about today is the idea of defense mechanisms. Let's have a palate cleanser from talking about oral, phallic, anal, all that stuff. And talk about something else. Defense mechanisms were in part his. He started this idea. They were further developed by his daughter. Defense mechanisms, if you know this term, you've probably heard it before, there are ways that the protects itself from anxiety, conflict, shame, or emotional pain by using methods of denial, projection, rationalization, repression, and displacement to kind of shield us, to kind of put a buffer or a barrier between us and the raw feeling. Essentially, it's just the ways that each of us tries to deal with discomfort in a unique way to ourselves and our history. A simple explanation is
that maybe you feel hurt, but instead of admitting that someone has hurt you, you become rude and dismissive towards somebody else in order to regain a sense of power. That's displacement. Sometimes someone who has been repeatedly romantically rejected will claim that they hate relationships. They just don't see the point. You know, love is lame. Monogamy is unnatural. You know, people who are in relationships are cringe. This is another defense mechanism. It's called reaction formation, where somebody responds with the radical opposite of what they are really feeling and what they really want in order to conceal their true desires. Another example, you fail a job interview. You fail a job interview. You really wanted it. And then you find
all the reasons to believe that the job would have sucked anyways instead of just feeling unhappy about it. You start convincing yourself, you know, I would have been miserable. I didn't like that guy who interviewed me. You know, I actually didn't really want that job. That's rationalization, creating a more acceptable explanation to protect yourself from disappointment, rejection, or vulnerability. Defense mechanisms are not automatically bad and they can really protect us from the emotional intensity of certain scenarios. The problem with defense mechanisms comes from when they become rigid and they stop us from seeing reality clearly, this is when they become maladaptive, maladaptive being something that is at the end of the day, unhelpful for your
functioning in your survival. Now, like I said, Freud had this initial idea, but it was his daughter, Anna Freud, who developed this more systematically and who gave words to what he was trying to describe. Anna is a really important part of this episode, because because she became a very well-known psychoanalyst in her own right. She is especially associated with child psychoanalysis, with ego psychology, with ways of human coping, with child development, and this still shapes how clinicians think about psychology to this day. Now, her relationship with her father was really complicated by modern standards.
She was insanely devoted to him. She worshipped him. She worked very closely with him. She cared for him during his illness. She also underwent analysis with him. He formed some of his ideas based on his relationship with his daughter. Now, this is the guy who created the Oedipus and the Electro Complex, so you can see why that's a little bit weird that his daughter was also not just a patient,
but a case study for him. He provided her with, yeah, with treatment and interventions and took notes on her own behavior. that's pretty unethical today. Actually, it was probably very unethical back then. And it was, when you think about Freud's work, a lot of what he talked about may have come from his relationship with his own daughter, which is a little bit weird. But Anna did, like, went on and was very, very successful.
And she built really incredible institutions. She worked with children affected by war. She helped basically establish childhood trauma, or the treatment of children with trauma and PTSD. as its own kind of clinical thing. She was very interested in children. She was very interested in their emotional lives. So her relationship with her father aside, the influence that she's had is positive and is remarkable and is an important part of this discussion of like Freud's legacy. Obviously she acted of her own accord. She was her own person. But there is a legacy to this that I think
does continue to be quite positive. And Anna's work going on from her father's is a big contribution. Okay, let's take a short break here. And when we return, let's talk a little bit more about his legacy and what psychologists think of him these days. So stay with us. I'm Ruby Carr, the host of the podcast, Encore. Check out our brand new episodes featuring music from the show that everyone is reheating as we speak. Heated rivalry. Join me as I go behind the songs that brought Shane and Elia together. I'll tell you the stories of Fice, My Moon, My Man, wolf parades, I'll believe in anything,
依然相当积极。安娜继承乃父之志的工作作好了巨大的贡献。好了，我们在这里稍事休息。等我们回来后，再聊聊他的遗产以及如今心理学家对他的看法。所以请继续收听。我是播客《安可》（Encore）的主持人鲁比·卡尔。快来收听我们的全新节目，其中包含每个人都在热议的剧集插曲。炽热的对决。和我一起深入探讨将肖恩和伊利亚聚在一起的歌曲。我会带你了解《Fice》、《My Moon, My Man》、《Wolf Parade》的《I'll Believe in Anything》、
and tattoos all the things she said, and how they all became a part of this global phenomenon. Stream encore on IHeart Radio, crave, or wherever you get your podcasts. Right now, the greatest tournament on the planet is happening on home soil, and the whole world showed up. Every match, somebody's dream ends, and somebody becomes a legend.
还有刺青乐队的《All the Things She Said》，以及它们如何成为这一全球现象的一部分。在 IHeart Radio、Crave 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Encore》。现在，地球上最伟大的锦标赛正在本土举行，全世界都为之欢呼。每一场比赛，都有人的梦想破灭，也有人成为传奇。
And if you're feeling all of it, the nerves, the heartbreak, the pure joy, you need people to feel it with. That's us. I'm Castle 1021, and this is the 1021 podcast, where the World Cup meets the culture. We react to every twist, say the takes nobody else will, play the games, call the shots, and celebrate this beautiful game the way it's meant to be. Loud, proud, and a little bit crazy. Upsets, penalties, the goat debate that never dies, we're in it with you, all the way to the final.
如果你感同身受，无论是紧张、心碎还是纯粹的喜悦，你需要有人陪你一起感受。我们就是。我是卡塞尔 1021，这里是 1021 播客，世界杯在这里与文化交融。我们对每一个转折做出反应，说出别人不敢说的话，玩游戏，掌控全局，并以应有的方式庆祝这项精彩的运动。喧嚣、自豪，还有点疯狂。冷门、点球、永恒的山羊（GOAT）之争，我们与你同在，直到决赛。
So don't watch it alone. Bring the passion, bring the hot takes. Listen to the 1021 podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brown's seen and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather, you know them. Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance,
所以别一个人看。带上激情，带上犀利的观点。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 1021 播客。嘿，波特兰迷们。凯瑞·布朗斯汀和弗莱德·阿米森在此。你们认识我们，或者说，你们认识他们。托尼和坎迪斯、妮娜和兰斯、
Spike, and yes, the chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning. breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters,
斯派克，还有那只鸡。这些年来，我们扮演了许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以本色出演，向大家介绍我们的全新播客《波特兰迷：AEO重温》（Podlandia, AEO Rewatch）。每周我们将从头开始重温一集《波特兰迷》，剖析小品，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，
revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin,
重游你熟悉并喜爱的波特兰取景地，并坦诚我们的创作过程。这一切到底是怎么拍出来的？为什么我们觉得那是主意？我们准备好聊聊这个了。把这些带到生活中。还有帮助将这一切变为现实的人们加入我们。特邀嘉宾、合作者和朋友们，包括导演乔纳森·克赖斯勒、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、
legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo, rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
传奇音乐家艾米·曼恩等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴了。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为他要写。我以为你们所有人都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方的 Podlandia、AEO 重温节目。
My first guest is Paris Hocin, Shakira, Luke and Ierian, Samira and Gracie. I'm so excited. On the bouncy bed. You have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to Sweet 305 where the group chat comes to life. What a f***. It's like a way of saying like,
我的第一位嘉宾是帕丽斯·希尔顿、夏奇拉、卢克和耶兰、萨米拉和格雷西。我太兴奋了。在弹跳床上。你有惊喜？很多惊喜。欢迎来到 Sweet 305，这里群聊变成了现实。怎么回事？这就像是一种说法，就像是，
oh, my God, hello, my friend, hello, hermina. What a fuck. Look, never I've ever been able to talk to. Except with my kids. My kids, if you know. Yes. I'm my amante. Oof.
哦，天哪，你好，我的朋友，你好，赫米娜。搞什么鬼。看，我从来没能跟谁聊过。除了我的孩子。我的孩子，如果你懂的话。是的。我的爱人。噢。
That's incredible. Yeah, the telenovela. You're the only person I know that loves a Yellow Starburst. It's really. No, no. There's no. I'm a man. Like you say,
这太不可思议了。对，就是那个肥皂剧。你是我认识唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。真的。不，不。没有。我是个男人。就像你说的，
I'd like to collaborate with this person. This is Sweet 305. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons as part of my Culture Podcast Network on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is Chelsea handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse.
我想和这个人合作。这就是 Sweet 305。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方，收听由莉莉·庞斯主持的、作为我的文化播客网络一部分的 Sweet 305。我是《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都在变糟。
The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'm a check you. Okay? If you do some...
世界变得越来越疯狂。亚曼妮卡来到这里，是要告诉任何对此负责的人，你才是问题所在。如果你来这里玩游戏，我会管教你的。好吗？如果你做了一些……
in the news that don't sound good, I'm gonna play you. Join Yamanika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out
新闻里听起来不太好的事情，我要曝光你。加入亚曼妮卡·桑德斯，在她的新播客中剖析本周最具争议的故事。由亚曼妮卡主持的《你才是问题所在》。你知道我刚刚发现
who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday as part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much.
西德妮·斯维尼是谁吗？每周三定期更新，作为我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”的一部分。如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。要么做得更好，要么少做一点，免得我得做那么多。
So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So Freud's influence is enormous, but so are the problems with his work. Now, his theories weren't evidence-based in the way that we would want today. You know, he didn't use random samples.
所以加入亚曼妮卡的每一集节目，她都会回答一个问题。谁才是问题所在？我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听由亚曼妮卡主持的《你才是问题所在》。因此，弗洛伊德的影响是巨大的，但他作品中的问题也同样巨大。现在，他的理论并不是我们今天所期望的那种基于证据的理论。你知道，他没有使用随机样本。
He didn't do control trials. He didn't do a intervention and no intervention condition. He developed many of his ideas through, as we said, case studies in clinic observations, theoretical reasoning. This doesn't automatically mean that his theories are worthless. They're not because we still use a lot of the ideas today. But it does mean that they weren't tested using the kinds of methods that we would expect now. His theories were also because of this, and in addition to this, very difficult to falsify. This basically means that they were hard to prove wrong. Now,
他没有做对照试验。他没有做干预和非干预条件。正如我们所说，他的许多想法是通过诊所观察中的案例研究、理论推理发展而来的。这并不自动意味着他的理论毫无价值。它们并非如此，因为我们今天仍然在使用很多这样的想法。但这确实意味着它们没有通过我们现在所期望的那种方法进行检验。正因为如此，除了这一点之外，他的理论也非常难以证伪。这基本上意味着它们很难被证明是错误的。现在，
this sounds like a really good thing, but in the field of psychology, falsifiability is one of the most essential principles that separate science from pseudoscience. Basically, you have to present a hypothesis or an idea that if there was proof to the contrary, is in, you could, find it and you could make an argument for it. This is to ensure that, you know, research isn't just being created based on a closed belief system. I'm going to explain this a little bit better. Let's give the example of the Oedipus complex. If somebody doesn't seem to have an Oedipus complex, that might be seen as proof that the Oedipus complex doesn't exist because here are all these people who aren't romantically attracted to their own fathers.
这听起来像是一件非常好的事情，但在心理学领域，可证伪性是将科学与伪科学区分开来的最重要原则之一。基本上，你必须提出一个假设或一个想法，如果有相反的证据，也就是说，你可以找到它，并且可以为它提出论据。这是为了确保，你知道，研究不仅仅是建立在封闭的信念系统之上的。我来更好地解释一下。我们以恋母情结为例。如果某人似乎没有恋母情结，这可能被视为恋母情结不存在的证据，因为这里有这么多人并没有对自己的父亲产生浪漫的吸引力。
But Freud's theories would say that is not true. They do. It's just that their desire is buried even deeper than expected in their unconscious. It's that they just don't admit it. It's not that the idea is false. It's that this person is just concealing that desire. So you can see how a lot of his ideas of the unconscious make it very easy to disprove what he's saying. because he can always just say, well, their coping mechanisms are shielding them from accessing
但弗洛伊德的理论会说，事实并非如此。他们有。只是他们的欲望比预期的更深地埋藏在他们的无意识中。只是他们不承认而已。并不是这个想法是假的。而是这个人只是在隐藏这种欲望。所以你可以看到，他关于无意识的许多想法是如何让人非常容易反驳他所说的话的。因为他总是可以说，好吧，他们的应对机制正在保护他们，使其无法接触到
this. Their memory or their feelings are repressed more than, more than you can imagine, and nothing that I can do can get them up, but those feelings are definitely still there. The other thing is, you know, if a patient agreed with Freud's interpretation of their problems, that's evidence that his interpretations are correct. But if a patient rejected his ideas, If a patient said, hey, I actually don't think that I have an issue with my parents. I actually don't think I had an issue in childhood. I really had a happy childhood. Like, I really disagree with you.
这一点。他们的记忆或他们的情感比你想象的还要受到更多的压抑，我所能做的任何事情都无法将它们唤醒，但这些情感绝对仍然存在。另一件事是，你知道，如果一个病人同意弗洛伊德对其问题的解释，这就是他的解释是正确的证据。但是，如果一个病人拒绝了他的观点，如果一个病人说，嘿，我其实不认为我和父母有什么问题。我其实不认为我在童年有什么问题。我确实有一个快乐的童年。就像，我真的很不同意你的看法。
He would say, well, that's because you have resistance. That's because of our therapeutic relationship. It's because you don't trust me. My theory is correct. Your memories are the ones that are incorrect. Your resistance to therapy is what's making you not believe. So as a result of this, a lot of people, have suggested that psychoanalysis is a bit of a pseudoscience. That's part of a much broader
他会说，好吧，那是因为你有阻抗。那是由于我们的治疗关系。那是因为你不信任我。我的理论是正确的。是你的记忆不正确。你对治疗的抗拒让你不相信。因此，由于这一点，许多人暗示心理分析有点像伪科学。这是一场更广泛的
debate, but it's important to say a lot of people don't agree with psychoanalysis. They don't think that every single problem has this weird unconscious origin. Sometimes the explanation is just a little bit more clear. That's for another time. I'm not going to touch that anymore because I know people have opinions. Another thing to note about how applicable his theories are, Freud developed most of his theories, as I said, from a small group of patients, but these patients weren't an accurate sample of people living across the world. They weren't even an accurate sample of people living in Europe or in Vienna. The majority of his patients were middle-class women of high-income. the majority across his entire career.
辩论的一部分，但重要的是要说，许多人并不同意心理分析。他们不认为每一个问题都有这种奇怪的无意识根源。有时解释只是更清晰一些。那是以后的话题了。我不再谈论这个了，因为我知道大家都有各自的看法。关于他的理论的适用性，另一件需要注意的事情是，正如我所说，弗洛伊德的大部分理论都是从一小群病人中发展出来的，但这些病人并不是世界各地人群的准确样本。他们甚至不是生活在欧洲或维也纳的人群的准确样本。他的大部分病人都是中产阶级高收入女性。在他整个职业生涯中，绝大多数都是如此。
So that makes our ability to generalize what he was saying difficult. His theories probably don't reflect every single individual in the world. They don't reflect different cultures. They don't reflect how different societies operate. They reflect the world around him when he was writing, which was very patriarchal, which was Victorian, European, deeply classed and deeply shaped by restrictive ideas about sexuality, gender, and race, even religion. You know, his ideas about women in particular, you know, they haven't aged very well.
因此，这使得我们推广他所说内容的能力变得困难。他的理论可能无法反映世界上的每一个人。它们不能反映不同的文化。它们不能反映不同社会的运作方式。它们反映的是他写作时他身边的世界，那个世界非常父权制、维多利亚式、欧洲化、阶级观念极深，并且深深受到对性、性别、种族甚至宗教的限制性观念的影响。你知道，特别是他对女性的看法，你知道，它们并没有经受时间的考验。
One in particular is another theory that I didn't mention before, but is important, which is seduction theory. early in his career Freud argued that some of his patients' symptoms, especially what was then called hysteria, could be traced back to childhood sexual abuse or unwanted sexual experiences.
其中一个特别的理论是我之前没有提到但很重要的理论，即诱惑理论。在他的职业生涯早期，弗洛伊德认为，他的一些病人的症状，特别是当时被称为歇斯底里的症状，可以追溯到童年时期的性虐待或不想要的性经历。
He was like, these women are crazy because at some stage in their past somebody did something to them that they didn't want to happen. Now that is an incredibly layered statement. That is, there is a lot of stuff that is wrong, some stuff that is, you know, most of it's wrong, actually, saying that, oh, this woman is hysterical because of trauma. A, kind of belittles the trauma and makes it
他当时的意思是，这些女人疯了，因为在她们过去的某个阶段，有人对她们做了她们不希望发生的事情。现在，这是一个具有极其丰富层面的陈述。也就是说，这里面有很多错误的地方，有些地方是，你知道，其实大部分都是错误的，说什么，哦，这个女人歇斯底里是因为创伤。A，某种程度上贬低了创伤，并使它
seem like, well, she's disturbing everybody else and that's the problem rather than what's happened to her. B, doesn't necessarily help them with that trauma. It just gives them a label without exploring how to move past what they've experienced. The biggest issue, C, was that a lot of these women were like, that didn't happen to me. Like, that you're trying to dismiss me by saying this thing happened to me, and I'm saying that it didn't. And so you can't just dismiss me and say,
看起来好像，嗯，她在打扰其他人，这才是问题所在，而不是发生在她身上的事情。B，不一定能帮她们摆脱这种创伤。它只是给她们贴上了一个标签，却没有探讨如何超越她们所经历的事情。最大的问题，C，是很多女性说，那没有发生在我身上。就像，你试图通过说这件事发生在我身上来打发我，而我说它没有发生。所以你不能直接打发我说，
oh, well, she's a victim of this, and that's why she's behaving that way. When I'm telling you that didn't happen. And he'd be like, well, it's just because you don't remember it. And that is a really, really messed up situation to put somebody in. And he, I don't really have words to describe, like, how, I'm sure you understand the layers of inaccuracy and the layers of complexity and the layers of just ridiculousness that is associated with that in many ways.
哦，好吧，她是这方面的受害，这就是她表现得那样的原因。而我告诉你那并没有发生。他会说，嗯，那只是因为你不记得了。这真是一个非常、非常糟糕的处境，把一个人置于其中。而他，我真的找不到词来形容，就像，我确信你理解与此相关的各种不准确、复杂和荒谬的层面。
You know, it's interesting because you see where he's getting at, and I hate to even say that, but he was like, you know, emotional drama creates physical reactions, and creates real pain later in life. And I'm seeing that in certain patience. And hopefully we can get them some help with that. But he, he wasn't, he didn't have that delicate gentleness towards it, that you should have. And again, he also tried to falsify people's memories and say, you know, this is what's happening. He later actually kind of moved away from that. He had, all these other ideas about like, oh, women who have sexual desire, it's because of, again, because somebody sexually assaulted them and all these weird feelings. And I don't think Freud came
你知道，这很有趣，因为你能看出他的意图，虽然我很讨厌这么说，但他当时的意思是，情绪戏剧会产生生理反应，并在晚年造成真正的疼痛。我在某些病人身上看到了这一点。希望我们能帮他们解决这个问题。但他并没有，他没有那种应有的细腻的温柔。再说一次，他也试图篡改人们的记忆，并说，你知道，这就是正在发生的事情。后来他其实有点放弃了这种想法。他有所有这些其他的想法，比如，哦，有性欲的女性之所以这样，又是，因为有人对她们进行了性侵犯，以及所有这些奇怪的感觉。我不认为弗洛伊德
close to recognizing like the impact that that had. And the impact that comes from talking about that and comes from just kind of experimenting with ideas and theories around that with real people. Like that is deeply harmful. It's very complex. The main issue, I think, with a lot of his theories, and it keeps coming back to this, is that they were incredibly speculative. They were also incredibly high stakes. They speculate over very serious, very impactful issues with people's lives. Sometimes he gets it right, but sometimes he doesn't. And getting it wrong was very, very harmful. And it's important that when we hear Freud's theories today, especially sometimes sometimes he doesn't. And of his theories around sex and around false memories and around the pre-conscious and the unconscious and around all these things, we take it at face value and understand, you know, how much we've developed psychology and how much we've developed our understanding of the mind and trauma from where he was acting in the late 1800s, early kind of 1900s. So beyond his theories, what was he actually like as a person? Freud was. Freud was.
接近于认识到这所产生的影响。以及通过谈论这些事情所产生的影响，以及通过与真人一起对周围的想法和理论进行试验所产生的影响。这具有极大的危害性。这非常复杂。我认为他的许多理论的主要问题，而且这个问题一直反复出现，在于它们具有难以置信的推测性。它们的风险也高得惊人。他们对人们生活中非常严重、非常有影响力的事件进行推测。有时他猜对了，但有时他猜错了。而猜错了则会带来非常、非常大的危害。重要的是，当我们今天听到弗洛伊德的理论时，特别是有些时候他猜不对的那些，关于性、虚假记忆、前意识、无意识以及所有这些事情的理论，我们要客观看待，并理解自从他在 1800 年代末、1900 年代初活动以来，心理学以及我们对心理和创伤的理解已经发展到了什么程度。那么除了他的理论，他作为一个真实的人究竟是什么样的呢？弗洛伊德是。弗洛伊德是。
famously very ambitious, very ambitious. He was very stubborn. He was very bold and he was apparently very aware of his own importance. He inspired a lot of deep loyalty in some people, a cultish following and strong opposition in others. His professional relationships in particular were very dramatic, like very gossip girl-esque, very, very dramatic. Partly because psychoanalysis, partly because psychoanalysts and psychoanalysis as a field became a movement during that time. It was like a cult. He also, as the founder of that movement, was very protective. He guarded membership very, very closely, and he did not respond well when others disagreed, which is funny because he wrote all about how the way we behave is representative of our,
出了名的雄心勃勃，非常有野心。他非常顽固。他非常大胆，而且显然对自己的重要性有着清醒的认识。他在一些人心中激发了深深的忠诚，一种类似于邪教的追随，而在另一些人中则引发了强烈的反对。他的职业关系尤其充满戏剧性，非常像《绯闻女孩》的风格，非常、非常具有戏剧性。部分是因为心理分析，部分是因为心理分析师和心理分析作为一个领域在那个时期变成了一场运动。它就像一个邪教。作为该运动的创始人，他也具有极强的保护欲。他对会员资格的把关非常、非常严格，当别人不同意他的观点时，他的反应并不好，这很有趣，因为他写了大量关于我们行为方式的文章，代表了我们的，
about it and our ego and our super ego and our impulses and our desires. And yet he really couldn't get his under control. For example, he had some very public, pretty major disagreements with people like Carl Jung and Alfred Adler, who we mention all the time on the podcast. Adler, who was very famous at the time and still is for his ideas of the inferiority complex, birth order theory, if you've ever heard about the eldest daughter syndrome. Alfred Adler is who you have to thank for that one. He talked a lot about personality, psychology as well. They had a massive falling out. And I love the drama of this. I love the drama that these
关于它以及我们的自我、超我、冲动和欲望。然而他真的无法控制好自己的这些。例如，他和卡尔·容格以及阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒等人有过一些非常公开、相当重大的分歧，我们在播客中经常提到阿德勒。阿德勒在当时非常有名，现在因其自卑情结、出生顺序理论等观点而依然著名，如果你听说过长女综合症的话。你就要感谢阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒。他也谈了很多关于人格心理学的内容。他们彻底闹翻了。我喜欢这种戏剧性。我喜欢这种戏剧性，这
two like psychological figures were like gossiping about each other and writing hit pieces and like little snarks in their papers. And he broke away from Freud. He was a psychoanalyst, partly because he thought Freud placed too much emphasis on sexuality and unconscious desire. He was a lot more Adler was a lot more interested in striving and social belonging and positive psychology and helping people overcome things and overcome insecurity. You know, where Freud really wanted to look backwards and to uncover hidden childhood conflicts, Adler was like, I'm focused on the future. I'm interested in goals. I'm interested in social context. I'm interested in meaning and how people find their place in the world. Even after he died, Alfred Adler, even after he died, Freud made
两个心理学界的人物竟然互相八卦，写抨击文章，在论文里互相挖苦。他与弗洛伊德分道扬镳。他是一名心理分析师，部分原因是他认为弗洛伊德过分强调了性和无意识欲望。阿德勒对奋斗、社会归属感、积极心理学以及帮助人们克服困难和克服不安全感要感兴趣得多。你知道，如果说弗洛伊德真的想回顾过去并揭开隐藏的童年冲突，那么阿德勒则表示，我专注于未来。我对目标感兴趣。我对社会背景感兴趣。我对意义以及人们如何在世界上找到自己的位置感兴趣。即使在他死后，阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒，甚至在他死后，弗洛伊德还对
really awful public comments about him. So here's this guy who's like the grandfather of psychology and psychology is meant to help people and he was messy. He got into some trouble. He also had a big fight with, with Jung. He had a big fight. He fought with everybody. Again, a lot of the time the criticism was like, you make things too sexual, dude. Like, you're, you make things weird. A lot of these men were like, we, you're not actually that focused on helping. people, you just want to dig into their, into their past. And each professional split, each argument fragmented psychoanalyst into, like, different disciplines and into different versions of what it meant. Freud was also very influenced by his own experiences, as we all are. But I think
他发表了非常糟糕的公开评论。所以，这家伙就像是心理学的祖父，而心理学本意是帮助人们的，但他却一团糟。他惹上了一些麻烦。他和容格也有过一场大吵。他大吵了一场。他跟所有人都吵过架。再说一次，很多时候受到的批评是，你把事情搞得太色情了，老兄。就像，你，你把事情搞得很怪异。很多这些男人都觉得，我们，你实际上并没有那么专注于帮助人们，你只是想深入他们的过去。每一次职业上的分裂，每一次争论，都将心理分析支离破碎成不同的学科，以及关于其含义的不同版本。弗洛伊德也深受自身经历的影响，就像我们所有人一样。但我认为
a lot of people like to think of him as this impartial genius who is making statements about the human condition that were universal, but he experienced a lot of social and political upheaval during his time, you know, the decline of the Austrian-Hungarian Empire, he lived through the First World War, through economic instability, rising anti-Semitism in Europe, and this really shaped the intellectual climate in which he worked in. And his real emphasis on aggression and desire and conflict and irrationality and the animalistic nature of the human soul was probably because he was witnessing a lot of violence and a lot of destruction. And he was Jewish as well.
很多人喜欢把他看作一个公正的天才，他对人类状况做出了普适的陈述，但他经历了许多社会和政治动荡，你知道，奥匈帝国的衰落，他经历了第一次世界大战、经济不稳定、欧洲日益严重的的反犹太主义，这确实塑造了他从事研究的知识氛围。他对攻击性、欲望、冲突、非理性以及人类灵魂的动物性属性的真正强调，很可能是因为他目睹了大量的暴力和破坏。而且他也是犹太人。
He was Jewish. He was living in Europe during a period of growing anti-Semitism. He was acutely aware of the impact of prejudice and exclusion and political instability. The Nazis literally burned. his books, like he was like on their hit list. And so it's important to see him as part of that as well and to not try and, like he was this human. He was human.
他是犹太人。他生活在欧洲反犹太主义日渐高涨的时期。他敏锐地意识到偏见、排斥和政治不稳定所带来的影响。纳粹甚至烧毁了他的书，就像他在他们的黑名单上一样。因此，将他视为其中的一部分也很重要，不要试图去，就好像他是个神一样。他是人。他只是一个人，他有很多想法，而这些想法深受他自己的经历、他自己的伤痛以及他自己的创伤的影响。他并不是很多人想象中的那个神。他非常、非常复杂。所以我想这就是我个人对他的遗产的看法。他推动了心理学的发展。毫无疑问。就像，任何时候你走进治疗师的办公室，
He was just one guy who had a lot of ideas that were really informed by his own experiences and his own hurts and his own trauma. And he wasn't the god that I think a lot of people think he was. He was very, very complex. And so I think that's where I stand personally with his legacy. He pushed psychology forward. There is no doubt. Like, any time you go into a therapist's office,
他们所做的一些事情，他们实践的一部分，他们学到的一些东西，都是因为弗洛伊德，以及因为他看待客户与治疗师之间治疗关系的方式。他还极大地拓展了我们对创伤的思考。我知道我说过他的做法饱受争议，但确实，在他开口之前，很多人根本不谈论这个，即使他谈论的方式并不是特别细腻。同样，那是时代的产物。他确实鼓励人们去探索隐藏的
something they do, some part of their practice, something they have learnt was because of Freud and because of how he saw the therapeutic relationship between client and therapist. He also really expanded. how we think about trauma. I know I said he did so controversially, but really a lot of people weren't talking about it until he did, even if he spoke about it in a way that wasn't particularly delicate. Again, it was of the time. And he really encouraged the exploration about hidden
情感生活。他真的就像，他真的很想，他是一个充满好奇心的人。他希望人们对别人的情感保持好奇，他真的想把人们当作复杂的个体来了解，这与心理学的运作方式截然不同。所以我们要为他这一点大加赞赏。他也非常完美主义，身上有很多盲点，非常多的盲点。这就是弗洛伊德的两面性。有趣的是，他整个职业生涯都在试图指出的那一点，
emotional lives. He really was like, he really wanted, he was a get curious. He wanted people to be curious about people's emotions and he really wanted to get to know people as complex individuals, which was very different from how psychology operated. So we're going to give him big, big ticks for that. He was also very flawed. He had a lot of blind spots, many blind spots. And that is the duality of Freud. And it's funny that the very thing he was trying to point to for his entire career,
也就是人类是多么复杂的生物。善与恶之间存在着斗争。无意识与有意识之间、本我与超我之间、现实与当下以及过去之间存在着斗争。就像，你能看出我的意思吗？他以可能是最伟大的一种方式作为一个人体现了这一点。所以这几乎有点诗意，不是吗？他作为一个人的身份几乎有点诗意，他与他的
which is like humans are these complex things. There's a battle between good and evil. There's a battle between unconscious and conscious between id and super ego between reality, your current moment and your past. Like, can you see where I'm getting? Like, he represented that as a person in probably one of the greatest ways. So it's almost a little bit poetic, isn't it? It's almost a little bit poetic who he was as a person, that he was, he represented his
作品结合得如此深厚，以至于他成为了他自己的态度、他自己的运作方式，而他的性格就像是他一直在探索的理论和思想的漫画。天哪。各位，那会是一篇多么有趣的文章，对吧？我不知道。我是不是扯远了？是的，我扯远了。好吧。回到正题。我只是觉得那会非常有趣。弗洛伊德的个人生活作为其作品的体现、作为其作品的代表，作为其作品的代言，会是一个多么有趣的博士论文主题。天哪，我真希望我能做那个。如果你想用这个，请便，请务必使用，当你在大概三年后完成时，把论文发给我。但这就是我们关于弗洛伊德的全部内容。
work so deeply that he was his own attitude and his own way of operating and his personality was like the caricature of the theories and the ideas that he was. exploring. Oh my God. Guys, that would be such an interesting essay, right? I don't know. Am I going off on a tangent here? Yeah, I am. Okay. Back to the thing. I just think that would be so interesting. Freud's personal life as a manifestation, as a representation, as a representation of his work would be such an interesting PhD topic. God, I wish I could do that. If you want to use that, go ahead, please do, and send me the paper when you're done in like three years with that. But that is all we have on Freud.
我说了这是一集较短的加长版。结果我好像讲了一个小时。所以谢谢你。如果你坚持听到了这里，我希望你对这个神秘的人有所了解。我希望你喜欢这集节目。哦，我还要说他有一个非常、非常棒的曾孙女。弗洛伊德的曾孙女有一个播客。对。
I said it was a bonus shorter episode. I'm like, have been speaking for like an hour. So thank you. If you have made it this far, I hope you have learnt something about this mystical man. I hope you enjoyed this episode. Oh, I'll also say he has a great, great granddaughter. Freud's great granddaughter has a podcast. Yeah.
它的名字叫《时尚神经症》（Fashion Neurosis），她甚至还请到了查莉·XCX（Charli XCX）来上节目。所以这是他遗产的另一个有趣部分，他的女儿是个播客主播。不，不是他的女儿。他的曾孙女是个播客主播。所以你看。也许我们应该请她来。
And it's called Fashion Neurosis. and she literally had like Charlie X-E-X on. So another interesting part of his legacy, his daughter is a podcaster. No, not his daughter. His great-great-granddaughter is a podcaster. So there you go. Maybe we should have her on.
也许我真的会联系她，然后就说，她可能不想谈论她的玄曾祖父。但这是一个非常有趣的八卦。感谢我们的研究员莉比（Libby）在这期节目中给予我们的帮助。另外，大家都来对她说声恭喜。我知道我刚才还在说心理学分析，但莉比刚刚在澳大利亚完成了三个月的博士研究，她正接近尾声，我们为她感到非常、非常骄傲，她是这个播客背后的隐藏力量。所以大家都来
Maybe I'll reach out to her actually and just be like, she probably doesn't want to talk about her great-great-great-great-great-great-grandfather. But very interesting tidbit. Thank you to our researcher Libby for helping us with this episode. Also, everybody say congrats. I know I was just speaking about P.A. but Libby just finished up three months in Australia doing PhD research and she's coming to the tail end and we're very, very proud of her and she is a hidden force behind this podcast. So everybody say
在下方的评论区向莉比表示祝贺。如果你关于弗洛伊德学到了新知识，如果你正在听 Spotify，也请在下方的评论区留言。确保在 Instagram 上关注我们，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。你还可以观看节目。不过不是这一集，因为这是一集加长版，但我们所有的其他节目都可以在 Netflix 上观看。你可以在 Substack 上关注我们的每周学习小组。这是一个系列，我每周为你将一篇学术文章拆解成五分钟的阅读量。但是天哪，直到下次再见，这是一集内容丰富的大型节目，我真的很喜欢。我们很快就会再聊。谢谢收听。注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。好的，回头聊。
congratulations to Libby in the comments below. If you learned something new about Freud, also leave that if you're listening to Spotify in a comment below. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. You can also watch episodes. Not this one though, because this is a bonus episode, but all our other episodes on Netflix. And you can follow us on Substack for our study of the week group. It is a series where I break down one academic article into a five-minute read for you once a week. But God, until next time, this has been a big episode and I really enjoyed it. We will talk very, very soon. Thank you for listening. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Yeah, talk later.
主场世界杯一生只有一次，我们一秒钟都不会错过。我是卡塞尔 1021。在 1021 播客中，我和我的团队像对待私事一样剖析每一场比赛，戏剧性、爆冷、让你整天都在讨论的辩论，足球、文化和混乱尽在一个地方。选个立场，我们已经选了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 1021 播客。嘿，波特兰迷们。凯瑞·布朗斯汀和弗莱德·阿米森在此。90年代的梦想在播客形式中得以延续。我们正在推出我们的全新播客《波特兰迷：AEO重温》（Podlandia, A.A.O. Rewatch），在这里我们将一起重温每一集《波特兰迷》，剖析小品，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的神秘面纱。
A Home World Cup only happens once in a lifetime and we are not missing a second. I'm Cassel. 1021. On the 1021 podcast, me and the crew, break down every match like it's personal, the drama, the upsets, the debates you'll be having all day, soccer, culture, and chaos in one place. Pick aside, we already did. Listen to the 1021 podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, A. A.O. rewatch, our brand-new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made.
还有帮助将这一切变为现实的人们加入我们。特邀嘉宾、合作者和朋友们，包括导演乔纳森·克赖斯勒、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、传奇音乐家艾米·曼恩等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴了。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为他要写。我以为你们所有人都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Podlandia、AEO 重温节目。
And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guestores, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia, AEO rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
怎么啦，家人们，我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯。嘿，怎么啦，大家。我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》（Everyone Watches Women's Sports）的主持人，这是一档来自 Together 的全新播客。我们将剖析女子体育界最大的头条新闻、病毒式传播的时刻以及每个人都在谈论的故事。从改变比赛表现的时刻到改变文化的对话，我们将为您带来我们的观点、辩论，并在过程中带来一些欢笑。因为每个人都在看女子体育。收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。
What's up, fam, it's sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the hosts of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together. We're breaking down the biggest headlines, the viral moments, and the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. From game-changing performances to culture-shifting conversations, we'll give you our takes, our debates, and a few laughs along the way. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports.
在 IHeart Radio 应用上。苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。我是《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。亚曼妮卡来到这里，是要告诉任何对此负责的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚刚发现西德妮·斯维尼是谁吗？
On the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was?
如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。要么做得更好，要么少做一点，免得我得做那么多。我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听由亚曼妮卡主持的《你才是问题所在》。我的第一位嘉宾是帕丽斯·希尔顿、夏奇拉、卢克和耶兰。你有惊喜？很多惊喜。
If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. My first guest is Paris Hilton, Shakira, Luke, and Yerrin. You have surprises? Many surprises.
欢迎来到 Sweet 305 播客，这里群聊变成了现实。怎么回事？你是我认识唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。这就是 Sweet 305。在这里，过度分享受到鼓励。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客上收听 Sweet 305。
Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast where the group check comes to life. What on? You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet 305. with Lille Pons on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast,
或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 IHeart 播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或在您获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。